This FIFA executive used an Onion article as proof
to defend himself against corruption charges. For
the uninitiated, The Onion is a satirical
newspaper. This is Jack Warner. He was the
vice president of FIFA. And in 2015, he was one
of several FIFA officials charged with fraud,
racketeering, and money laundering. I know
this because I made a giant video about FIFA
corruption and know way too much about this
organization. But I had to cut this tidbit
because it just didn't fit. But this one's just
too good not to share. Warner recorded a video of
himself holding up this obviously fake article,
which says that FIFA had announced an impromptu
2015 World Cup that was starting that very
day. He thought it was a genuine news report,
and he held it up as evidence that there was an
American conspiracy to get back at FIFA for not
choosing them to host the World Cup. I mean,
just a skim through this article reveals how
clearly satirical it is. It ends by saying the
U.S. was leading the defending champs, Germany,
in the opening match, getting 12 penalties
in the first 3 minutes. But even still